- Get this, first I call her to say,
"Honey where are you?"
'cause I found out I was
not gonna be dancing again.
So I said, "Honey where
are you right now?"
She said, "I'm sitting on
the runway in the plane,
we're about to take off
to come cheer you on."
I said, "Well I need you to save the day."
And she said...
- I said, "No way".
(audience laughs)
I said, I was,
- Are you insane?
The whole thing was
that I was on the plane.
I had found out that
she had broken her arm,
and I was like I'm still gonna come.
I'm gonna be there to
support her and I'm gonna
be there to take her to the
hospital and everything.
And I'm flying in, I'm on
the plane about to take off,
like wheels are moving and
she calls me and she goes,
"Sailor, I found the silver lining."
(audience laughs)
Don't I do a good
Christie Brinkley voice?
- Yes, you do a
really good, yes.
- She goes, "Sailor I
found the silver lining."
I was like, "What you
need me to stop at CVS?
"Like do you need anything,
anything from home,
"like bring the dog maybe?"
And she's like, "No, you should go on
Dancing With The Stars."
(laughing)
And I was like, "No."
I had spend the summer like
chilling with my boyfriend,
and my dog in the Hamptons,
like just sort of like
being very low key.
- [Kelly] I want your life.
(laughing)
Who ultimately came up
with the idea though?
Who, was that you?
- I think it was her.
- But everybody kind of
came up with the idea
at the same time cause I like,
when something really bad happens
you gotta find the silver lining right?
And I thought, and you
know, It's "Up Town Girl",
I mean that's like my theme
song ever since you know.
It can't just like be anybody.
It's gotta be one of my girls.